au pied des montagnes de l'atlas pour
bords de la méditerranée à narbonne
plage dans l'autre un camping ou plus
exactement 1 comme vacances le poids
international de vacances des foyer léo
lagrange de france qui étire ses
installations à quelques jets de pierre
de la plage monsieur audibert le
directeur de ce camp international
qu'est-ce qui a présidé à sa fondation
vient c'est le club léo lagrange de
narbonne qui a présidé à la fondation de
ce camp et nous avons créé un cas
international effectivement puisque nous
avons des vacanciers de tous les coins
de france qui viennent même de
l'étranger et même des pays francophones
d'afrique
nous avons aussi créé à côté un centre
familial où nous recevons des familles
et le contact jeunes et familles
s'établit très bien il n'y a pas de
problème pour une modique somme
actuellement de 13 francs par jour
parution complète comprise bien entendu
nous offrons aux jeunes et aux familles
des vacances saine et agréable
le camp a débuté en 1957 dans un terrain
très peu aménagés
quelques toiles de tente type marabout
quelques baraquements de bois et une
cuisine tout à fait sommaire maintenant
évidemment vous pouvez vous rendre
compte des installations qui ont se sont
bien améliorés et l'an dernier c'est
sans plus de 500 vacanciers sont passés
au centre et nous avons fourni 13 mire
70 jours les vacances
eh bien ces jeunes gens ces familles
qu'elles la cance proposez vous eh bien
il suffit de suivre les activités de la
journée pour voir que les jeunes sont
employés et sont distraits du matin
jusqu'au soir
ça commence par un verrouillage mattila
puis le petit déjeuner puis bien entendu
la matinée et l'après midi sont occupés
aux jeux de plage mais le soir nous
pensons aussi à des veillées veillée
jeux veillées culturelles excursions si
étude du milieu du milieu naturel du
milieu
et bien entendu pour être resté fidèle
au message que nous a laissé léo
lagrange nous voulons offrir aux jeunes
des vacances scène agréable et qui en
même temps les élèves les permettre de
s'évader du milieu routinier quotidien